-Good evening. I'm Seth Myers.
This is late night we hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
In the wake of Russian President
Vladimir Putin's invasion
of Ukraine, President Biden
today announced the full scope
of sanctions against Russia,
including blocks
on Russian banks that hold
$1 trillion in assets
and their ability to do
business in dollars, euros,
pounds and the yen.
Which explains why Russia just
tried to buy a fighter jet
with a picture of a bored ape.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ]
Is good for one jet, no?
[ Normal voice ] Russian
President Vladimir Putin
declared war last night against
Ukraine, and this is nice,
Trump offered to host
the after-party.
That's right,
Vladimir Putin declared war
last night against Ukraine
but said that Russia
has no plans to, "occupy."
Oh, buddy,
nobody has plans to occupy.
We all remember when our war
in Iraq was supposed to
be a three-day weekend.
You're like that guy who thinks
he is going to have one drink
with his old college friends --
No!
You're going to wake up at dawn
in a karaoke booth
with your socks on your hands
saying,
"Oh, man, did I do islands in
the stream with sock puppets?"
[ Laughter ]
After President Biden imposed
an initial round of sanctions
against Russia, the Russian
Foreign Affairs Ministry warned,
"There should be no doubt that
sanctions will receive
a strong response." Come on.
You think you can attack us?
This is America.
We attack ourselves.
We good.
Following last night's Russian
invasion of Ukraine,
the price of oil has jumped to
above $100 a barrel,
for the first time since 2014.
And I'm the second person to
tell you that
if your friend has a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
According to new study,
the erectile dysfunction drug
Viagra can be used as a new
treatment for dogs
with a rare eating disorder.
Though it's not going to help
with the embarrassment
at the pharmacy.
It's for my dog!
An eating disorder.
Well, it's rare. So you wouldn't
have heard of it.
And finally actor
Leonardo DiCaprio announced
this week that he has made a
significant investment
in a 110-year-old
champagne house.
Not his first choice.
But it's hard to find a
24-year-old champagne house.
[ Laughter ]
You get it.
That was the monologue,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was the monologue.